[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in sallys welt
heute habe ich wieder einen gast in der
küche eigentlich schon seit mehreren
tagen und ich freue mich auch sehr dass
sie wieder zu gast ist tatsächlich ist
mein heutiger gast nämlich nicht zum
ersten mal da sondern schon beim zweiten
besuch aber es fühlt sich an als wäre
sie einfach schon immer in meinem leben
ich werde jetzt erstmal in türkischen
tee aufsetzen denn ich hab hier schon
wasser gekocht und teeblätter
vorbereitet dies den tee auf denn mein
heutiger gast hat auch schon so eine
kulturelle verbundenheit zu mir muss ich
sagen sie ist griechin ist wunderschön
sie ist mir sehr sympathisch schon von
anfang an und er liebt sie alle sehr
heute ist nicolet sogar
[Applaus]
bachmann der
heidecksburg
werden so die antwort war schnell drin
ist so herzlich willkommen und roche
produkt ist muss die antwort darauf hat
im türkischen immer oft so
einfach so ja immer nach antwortspiel
wortspiele und antworte ich freue mich
sehr wieder hier zu sein ja ich meinte
wasser schon öfter ja und wir haben auch
schon gekocht und gebacken und es ist
auch schon vieles gut gelaufen vieles
auch noch besser gelaufen
und wir wollen jetzt heute ein bisschen
kochen und bei zu gast bei sally wisst
ihr ja auch da haben wir sonntag
challenges mit dabei im spiele mit dabei
und fragerunden natürlich auch fragen
aus der community an dich oder an uns
und heute habe ich mir gedacht machen
wir mal was türkisches wir bereiten
türkischen reist sehr kochen vor allem
welche rauen freue mich so ich dachte
wenn ich jetzt anfange wenn wir jetzt
anfangen zu backen dann eskaliert
vielleicht hh lehnen uns zurück an die
advents torte die uns sehr gut gelungen
ist alle kerzen
an die cupcakes die tatsächlich sehr gut
gewehrt hat sehr gut aus gut und werden
auch festgestellt dass nicolet am besten
ein konditor brauchen gut aussehen und
was ich zu hause der er als vor drei
jahren sieht dann der muss aber auch
wissen können und
geld ran glocken geschickt
das geld verdienen dr oetker persönlich
weist mit dem kompletten anwesen und so
dass der rechtsstaat so machen wir das
nicht deswegen aber gedacht heute
türkischen reist und dann gibt es noch
in auberginen hackfleisch gericht dass
auch tatsächlich muss ganz
traditionelles und ich muss sagen so
türkische und griechische küche die sind
sich so ähnlich
ja ich denke schon es unterscheidet sich
immer so ein bisschen nicht glaubt von
den gewürzen er aber ich glaube sowieso
dass wenn du aus dem südländischen
bereich kommt dann hast du ein gefühl
dafür dann schmeckt er definitiv auch
hat sie nur eine andere bezeichnung also
ich finde so türkisch griechisch
italienisch spanisch aber auch teilweise
bosnisch-serbische hat sich anja die
junge küche auch mehr ja ich würde sagen
wir sind schon ready und währenddessen
wenn man dann gleich die fragen
beantworten und ich habe mir gedacht
später noch nie in mannheim bei uns im
shop das werden wir heute heute wird ein
großer tag kommt was alles getan was
habe ich gedacht wir werden später auch
den showmaster tage noch kennenlernen er
hat die spieler für dich vorbereitet um
die challenger und ihr müsst auch wissen
dass ich vorher auch nicht weiß was wir
machen als ich weiß schon dass wir ein
spiel machen musik spielt zum beispiel
wird es später geben und wir gehen den
job aber ich sehe die fragen auch nicht
woher also da sind wir schon sehr sehr
ehrlich ich glaube dass stefan raab
früher weiß ich nicht ob das immer so
ehrlich war
okay komm lass uns loslegen der nach dem
türkischen reich ja was gibst du isst ja
schon gern türkische ja ich esse alles
sehr gerne also ja ich bin bei der
ähnlichen küche immer so ein bisschen
vorsichtiger und weil ich da etwas schon
ein paar erfahrungen gemacht habe dass
meine zunge nicht so ganz mit klar
gekommen aber ansonsten einmal quer
durch den durch den globus der als wären
dafür einfach so einen türkischen
rundkornreis dann diese note sind diese
kleinen tscheche heißen die auf türken
summen oder in
salzgitter und dann habe ich jetzt ein
sonnenblumenöl und das erste was wir
machen soll wie es heißt an meiner mama
gelernt und so wie es die mama zeigt ist
immer richtig kannst du den reis da
reingeben dass man ein zeichen genau
salsa und mit heißem wasser weil man
muss auch wissen wer einst ich habe eine
zeitlang einfach nicht mehr so gründlich
gewaschen aber bei reis es schon so dass
ein produkt das kommt das wird
importiert und insekten das ist nicht
ganz so hygienisch viel staub will ich
nutzen
deswegen sollte man den schon gut
waschen ja wahrscheinlich auch um die
starkes und sicher los diana
der wird nämlich später schön fein nicht
klebrig jetzt ordentlich salz rein
wirklich das wird später wieder runter
gewaschen und da kann es jetzt einfach
das heiße wasser so drauf geht wie lange
hast du den ganzen 18 minuten und wenn
ich ruhig ordentlich rein und den
waschen wir das später einfach schön aus
immer deine foto hier weg sagt man mal
nach der verbrennung zu ich habe
immerhin noch so
haben wir gleich noch mal wasser aber
das passt jetzt erstmal also rises
vorbereitet und dann haben wir hier noch
die zutaten du musst mal die auberginen
zeigen ich habe eben schon gesagt hab
noch nie so auberginen gesehen so keller
das ist ja wahnsinn aber du hast ja
vorgestern abend schon damit gekocht
doch so lecker lecker ich finde die sind
auch so ein bisschen wie so ein
fleischesser es tatsächlich also da
finde ich brauch mal eigentlich was die
konsistenz und so angeht kein fleisch
man kann doch echt gut damit arbeiten
also wenn gewässer nimmt der sohn über
jeden ball
ich finde die auch recht schön
tatsächlich und dann schneidet man die
einfach ihr so feine kleine scheiben ja
in der community wird auch schon gefragt
du kochst ja ganz gerne total du hast
auch ein kochbuch geschrieben das habe
ich natürlich hat sie mir damals ja noch
bevor wir uns persönlich kann und ich
mag so die farben haben
ich würde sagen wir machen so so so
kleine würfelchen massong so
[Musik]
hat die kann man echt ganz gut sogar
dass uns dem rat muss ich sagen
marinieren und ziehen lassen mit perfect
ja
also schon fast durch fritz ja ja immer
wir können aus dem nix machen salz du
sie bei zucchini auberginen ist es ja
immer so der eine sagt ja gesagt nein
ich brauche immer viel geld da dran also
meine mama hat immer gesagt ich habe
mich schon wie
dabei
botter bewiesen dafür ist der roboter
rollt man sagt ja immer und meine mama
sagt jetzt tatsächlich immer dass man
aubergine galten muss damit sie auch
sowie sind die bitterstoffe loswerden
und damit sieht es so wahnsinnig
aufnehmen als sonst sind ja wirklich
schwammig wer so ein schwamm tatsächlich
ja schon magst du sie rein haben ist es
so gut von der größte und gestein
verstand wegen eines stand und beim
kochen ist das ewig so
wie beim bak gott sei dank
das ist ja hier das ist ja mein kommando
die flexibilität da guck mal du hast
jetzt so stix gemacht ja das macht das
ergänzt sich doch ganz gut
[Musik]
gott danken wir jetzt auch ordentlich
salz dazu
du sollst dir auch noch weil glaube aber
dass da nichts dran macht das ist ja ich
weiß ja wie papier ja finde ich auch
termin und ich sag jetzt verliert die so
ein bisschen flüssigkeit diesen
bitterstoffen wobei mittlerweile ja auch
obst und gemüse so gezüchtet wird dass
die dinge kreis auf eis da gar keine
bitterstoffe gar nicht erst heißt es ja
auch manchmal richtiges fuß produkt das
wissen haben sie legale mittel und korn
wie das an gezüchtet wird das event sind
ja dann
würde ich sagen können wir hier noch so
ein bisschen das gemüse china gibst du
mir erstmal für die zwiebel justin
oder schminke im gesicht
die zwiebeln ikea sowie
verein hätte gerne püriert schon ja aber
tatsächlich bist du glaub ich mein
erster gast zumindest in dem monat der
die zwiebel schälen und schneiden kann
und da war trocken kann das ist so ja
die anderen da wäre alles wäre alles
zuvor hier du da war eko fresh da ja da
muss ich auch erstmal zeigen wie man die
zwiebel schinkels jahre wieder gehört ja
aber dann macht der studie gut ab ach so
und aaron troschke war dann schon da wie
ist das so bei dem mit zuzog weil das
ist ja so dass dinge das ist ja auch ein
bisschen übergeschwappt und ich kann das
ja gar nicht immer essen was hat
manchmal zu kraft ich krieg das
sodbrennen das ist also gerade morgens
denke ich mir das ist schon ne ist schon
heftig also ich finde da ist so viel
glutamat drin dass ich vertrag ist desto
eher ab und zu essig x naja
ich mich erhoben hat und die kinder da
jetzt nicht so drauf abfahren würden
aber auch die haben den konsum
specialist obama hier habe ich sag dir
was noch viermal im jahr essen die
messer sind so super unschuldige ich
muss was andere einwerfen dass die
meiste richtig das schön das brot nicht
darum das ist auch nicht wenn man jetzt
wie bestellt und
ein bisschen aber du siehst ja hier
ach quatsch geht's riesig meine güte
zunächst übernehmen nee ich habe die
bibel noch schafft ich hab's bekommt
schnell hier ich habe ja schon okay
ein extralob für dich und
32 ist daher immer frisch und da haben
wir viel mit zwiebel knoblauch ja die
zwiebel ist die königin der küche und
der knoblauch der könig aber die hast du
nicht an talent bibel knoblauch und
olivenöl
ich sag ja auch gute butter und frische
sahne ist ja immer so meint mein slogan
und ich habe zum beispiel eine freundin
die markt keine zwiebeln und wenn du
keine zwiebelmarkt ich will jetzt hier
keinem zu nahe treten ist eigentlich gar
nicht anfangen zu kochen
genau mein opa ist und es kommt ja auch
erst koch feeling auf wenn irgendeiner
knoblauch oder zwiebeln anfängt
anzubraten weiß tun und dann noch in der
türkischen küche tomatenmark die basis
ja alles alles gut ja wenn ich keine
drei mutter im haus habe ich sagt sich
durch durch einkaufsliste bereit
mindestens zwei kilo butter ja
ja aber du bist ja auch die könige des
olivenöls
großem vertrauen dann haben wir hier und
da wird sagte rice
hier kochen war das auberginen und
ich muss sagen die tomaten die jetzt
zwar so dazu gelegt und seien im winter
benutze ich keine tomaten schmecken ja
ich bin eher so der soma tomaten schon
wenn sie hier auch wachsen deswegen ganz
sitzt zwar zur deko dazu aber ich will
euch eure hat im winter einfach tomaten
man muss nur lose zu nehmen ja die
werden dann erntefrisch eingepackt kann
den vollen geschmack ja es ist wie leute
die im winter mit erdbeeren hand hier
und es ist halt immer so eine sache da
kann man ja auch eiswürfel im
unternehmen jahren vor allem finde ich
die importware einfach immer
nicht wo man gut zu gehen außerdem sind
schon gestellt gehabt und das ist gut so
wie ich das mit fingernägeln im
aufmacher sondern dort wird es tut
natürlich deinen augen herz bei dem
messer co woanders an das inzwischen für
alle die immer
die kommentare gelesen unter dem letzten
video mit meinen nägeln sie bleiben
übrigens ist aber schon so dass man dann
generell als ich habe auch gestern ihr
fragen gesammelt ja und man muss schon
generell immer damit rechnen dass
menschen viele viele vorurteile haben
also einen kommentar war
ich mag nicole es sehr und ich mag dich
sehr aber eigentlich passt sie nicht in
deiner küche weil ihr von grund auf
verschieden seiten und dann frage ich
mich so wie kommt man darauf so was zu
sagen und es sind ja wirklich menschen
die einfach viel aufs äußere auf
optische einfach nur wert legen und
hast du oft damit zu kämpfen oder die
einen schon immer durch so auf der das
frühere einfach total aber ich habe auch
oft schon die erfahrung gemacht dass die
leute mir mal den minute eine chance
geben und auf das hören was ich sage vor
allen dingen auf den inhalt was sie dann
sagen ach die ist ja ist ja doch nicht
so doof oder die hat mir trotzdem
irgendwie ein mehrwert der nation zu
bieten und wenn so was wir gerade also
gesagt dass wir so verschieden sind es
wäre ja so schade wenn das der realität
wird ein spieler erstes mal dass aber
die leute glauben dass weil das die
bubble ist er und es wäre ja auch so
schade wenn menschen immer nur
zueinander finden die post gleich sind
das ist eine ergänzung und ich sehe auch
in meinen kommentaren immer ganz genau
wer die kollektion kennt wir sind noch
nicht da und er ist ganz oft so dass wir
auch dann viele schreiben auch privat
schreiben und sagen kratz vielleicht
hätte ich mich so erstmal gar nicht auf
ihren account getraut ja hat er auch die
chance nicht gegeben wäre aber nach
unserem letzten podcast muss ich auch
sagen haben ganz viele geschrieben wie
toll sie dich finden und sehr dankbar so
ja dass du dich kennengelernt haben und
das zu ihnen sehr viele gibt man muss
auch sagen als für alle die zeit
vielleicht das erste mal die nicolet
sehen sie hat donnerstags zum beispiel
ist es nur ein paar von ihr ostsee macht
sind donnerstags immer den dirty
donnerstag hat sich immer ganz schmutzig
an aber ist wirklich ein format nun
brachte im podcast aber es ist ein
format auf instagram wo man einfach als
mann oder frau fragen stellen kann
anonym violett beantwortet fast alle
fragen ja und da geht es eben nicht nur
um
sondern ehe zwischen menschlichkeit ja
das zwischenmenschliche ist das was dich
auch so besonders machen wo du einfach
wenn ich den menschen viel zurück gibt
viel positives gibt ich habe mir auch
schon ganz viel davon abgeguckt muss ich
sagen wo ich sage okay das hat mich
jetzt echt gestärkt was ich da gehört
habe und wo ich für mich einfach für
mich und meine persönlichkeit und auch
meine familie meine partnerschaften vier
ausgezogen aber seine community ich habe
ja wirklich spiele von deinen seinen
followern und abonnenten adaptieren
dürfen und das sind ganz herzliche ihre
ganz herzliche liebe menschen die total
die das glaube ich auch manchmal sehr
genießen sich öffnen zu können
also ich habe auch leute von line fall
war die 2 spielt uhr tickets jetzt
gekauft haben und so ich habe mich total
drüber gefreut tja ist auch richtig
schön und wir werden auch später
bestimmt und paar bei uns in mannheim
treffen wenn nämlich gestern schon das
dritte jahr kommen ich bin mal gespannt
ich denken soll wir sind mit unter der
woche und bin wahrscheinlich den mega
anlauf geben aber ich denke trotzdem
dass der eine oder andere nach
feierabend vorbeikommen wird und sich
auch sehr früh wir freuen uns über jeden
fall über jeden ja jetzt brauchen wir
erstmal fertig und dann gucken wir wie
es weiterläuft also den reis geben wir
jetzt in ein sieb und waschen den und
waschen gehen und am ende des tages auch
im naturprodukt das dürfen fehle das
vergessen es ist tatsächlich was
vielleicht nicht wissen reise sind
naturprodukt mail zum beispiel sind wir
auch diese diese zeit wo cookie dough
einfach so im trend war und in amerika
ist eine fast schon wie so eine pandemie
so der epidemie ausgebrochen weil
menschen einfach magen-darm-beschwerden
bekam durch durch den rohen teig und
viele dachten dass während die eier sind
nicht die eier sondern es ist das mehl
und wenn man unbehandeltes unerhitzte
mail zum beispiel zu sich nimmt es halt
naturprodukt das ist draußen auf dem
feld wächst es da ist das das geheimnis
wird erst keine rohen teig du kriegst
bauchschmerzen das ist mir da hab das ja
ja ja wir quasi draußen eben das
getreide auf dem feld ist da wandern
tiere drüber da fliegen die töte drüber
und düngen den ganz schön und der wird
hier nicht behandelt der wird er quasi
nur geschält und gemahlen ja bist du
denn nur das eigentlich ja
also den war schon mal kurz kalt ab
[Musik]
ja das war es eigentlich eine
vorbereitung heißt hier haben wir eine
panne für den reis die können wir kurz
erwärmen ich habe meine pfanne hier fürs
gericht und das erste was du machst ist
es her da reingeben im griechischen
kennt man den reisen nicht mit nudeln
ein nein aber haben reisnudeln die wir
sehr gerne
[Musik]
krippe und reis nudeln
gnocchi
oder ich sagen leichten hauptgang und
dann darfst du nämlich die nudel und
schau mal rein geben ist es schon an
hier ja und das ist auch gleich warm und
die werden ganz kurz angebraten schon
bis ein bisschen leicht hellbraun wäre
okay leicht man muss auch was und das
nicht zu dunkel werden aber das ist gut
und die butter geben wir erst später
dazu weil sie bitte jetzt so ein
bisschen ans kollegium genau ich hab
hier olivenöl und gibt hier schon mal
die zwiebel nicht fleisch weil
damit sie hier nicht zu dunkel werden ja
und dann kann ich jetzt erst mal auf
hoher stufe das hackfleisch krümelig
brand
[Musik]
ich habe ich hier schon mal die zwiebeln
und den knoblauch rein was hat sie gibt
eine öl reingemacht am sonntag reichlich
damit wenn ich jetzt olivenöl genommen
hätte dann willst du stark nach oliven
und schmecken und deswegen dem motto
erneut rares und will dann den
buttergeschmack okay aber die sehen ist
super aus und schön schön ich helfen
und dann darfst du denn reiste zu mir
schön anbraten zimmer toll am tag der
haarwäsche zwiebeln an zu graben
naja du hast heute morgen gewachsen ja
geht nicht hierüber
recycelt und recycelt die letzten tage
das heißt ich kann mir morgen richtig
die rübe schrubben nation aber trocken
campo regelrechtes toren leben nach dem
haarewaschen bestimmt mein leben jetzt
bestimmt man das verstehen das verstehen
meiner herr zum beispiel haare waschen
bestimmt mein leben ich hab früher ich
habe
jeden tag haare gewaschen ist es so ja
was war das kürzeste wasser und haaren
hatte ich hatte jemals ja nach der
ersten schwangerschaft ist bei frauen
oft so dass wir dann so eine veränderung
brauchen und da habe ich märkten ist
nichts für mädchen
ja ich bin doch so ein langer mädchen
ihr wisst schon mal wieder trauen
sondern so einen languedoc aber
ich traue mich nie
dafür mag ich meine haare zu sehen
aber es schon zeitaufwendig mit den
haaren aber ich hatte vorher ja im
languedoc das hat noch länger gedauert
immer dem stegreif heraus dann richtig
was beraten beim wort vor vier jahren
war anstrengender als wenn ich die haare
einfach lang trage da muss man sich ja
muss so lange haare ich kann es ja auch
keine laufen richtig machen das war
und
ich krieg da die fragen gleich aus der
community aber eine frage weiß ich noch
ich habe nämlich gelesen was ist deine
lieblings haarfarbe an dir
hat es ja die war sehr gerne ich war ja
mein ganzes leben oder fast mein ganzes
leben schwarz haarig was ich ganz ganz
toll finde ich konnte das auch immer
ganz gut tragen weil ich immer sehr
stark geschminkt bin und ich finde wenn
die haare so dunkel hast brauchst du
hier farbe
und dann war ich mal eine zeitlang was
heller und blonder das kannte ich auch
sehr schön und das rote gefällt mir auch
aber ich mag auch rothaarige frauen
gerne ich mag frauen die natur rot sind
mit sommersprossen in ganz hellenthal
haben euch bitte einfach so schön
deswegen habe ich das buch gelebt das
parfum ja die bauelemente barbara meier
noch mal zocken heute zweite stadt
schöner frau und kind so auch die serie
das verfilmen denn eine serie dazu ja
also nicht nur das buch und dem film
sondern praktisch auch in serie und dies
auch recht gut das sind so schöne frauen
ja das ist bisschen heiß hast du mal ich
nehme einfach hier so weit ich kann dir
auch in natürlich du hast extra dafür
entwicklung
europas auch in die wand krokodil oder
das
super super hier gibt es alles
ich gehe mal ganz kurz die auberginen
auch auswaschen es sieht man nämlich
auch ganz gut die ganze flüssigkeit die
austritt muss mit aber auswaschen
[Musik]
es sieht schon super lecker richtig
lecker bin ich da auch ganz lecker ja
das kommt jetzt die auberginen rein ich
glaube ich nehm tatsächlich nicht aber
doch zwei historische die dann schon die
kann ich ja für morgen auch schön mit
anbraten und bei denen ist jetzt echt so
weit dass du die butter zugeben da ein
größerer beste momentan recht einfach um
hammermäßig gut ich mache und
dann brauchen wir nämlich gleich das
wasser zum aufgießen und
da bringt man jetzt auch so ein bisschen
die reichs stärke an und dann wird er
später richtig richtig schön und beim
persischen reißen machst du ja auch
gerne da will man ja diese kruste ja ein
ganz normales körper
ja
ich mache dem reiskocher und ich mache
und auftaktdoppeln rein das ist eine
schicht kartoffeln ich mache ja ja ja
und mit guten aktionen basra
ich schon noch ein bisschen mit kurkuma
für die farbe und ich mache mich noch
kurkuma in nudelwasser rein damit nudeln
noch ein bisschen gelber werden
ich trinke kurkuma tatsächlich auch ganz
gerne mit kurkuma ersten grades noch
golden age oder
hagebutte und manchmal noch ap gut für
haut haare und nägel kannst du dem
persischen reich schon mal gemacht in
dem video in dem video noch nicht aber
in einem hübschen
aber
auch lecker der papa meiner besten
freundin ins iraner ja eigentlich muss
ich mein papa roger morgen eigenes papa
motsch herkommen und papa manchmal
iranisch kochen und dabei so sehr wie
oft olic ja viel frischen joghurt mit
nobler später lag war betrachtete wasser
aufgießen bei dir deine reisetätigkeit
ordentlich aufgießen
noch mehr
speicher und
kurz aufkochen genau und dann kann man
die hitze schon bisher unternehmen der
kocht jetzt quasi noch ein bisschen salz
muss noch dran
ich schmecke dann auch immer das reis
wasser so ein bisschen ab
ich bin tatsächlich auch ein mensch ich
find auch mal sollte nudelwasser
abschmecken
wir sehen da zu wenig trainiert man
schmecken gemüse nicht
ja aber bei reis ist noch mal was
anderes wie ich finde als bei nudeln ich
bin zum beispiel wenn nicht nur die und
koche mir ist aufgefallen die meisten
leute nehmen gilt so kleinen topf nudeln
du brauchst mir nudeln ja hat eine
badewanne voll wasser und schwimmt
unternehmens das nudelwasser auch
schmecken wie das salz wasser im meer
hier auch
wenn ich mich in vorsichtiger hier darf
es auch leicht zu salzig schmecken und
dann ist es nur fällt
nun gehen wir da jetzt nämlich einfach
den deckel drauf
und lassen das schönkirchen
und hier gebe ich noch paprika mark dazu
der thema danzig mit dem einfrieren her
hier kann mich eben gefragt was es ist
ich habe immer eiswürfel behälter voll
mit paprika mark und tomatenmark in
gefahr weil ich meistens paprika und
tomaten mag ihm beim türken kauf und
sind immer so probiert so groß ist also
ich krieg das auch nicht mehr meine mama
schon ich nicht und irgendwann habe ich
mir angewöhnt ist alles in portionen
einzufrieren und dann kann man die sich
einfach dafür aus die idee des volkes
machst du weiter rühren ich gebe einfach
alles dazu
gesagt erwarten
das ist wie früher das spiel die immer
du bist raus
da wird nichts verschwendet
wie war das bei euch in der kindheit
auch so ein bisschen sparsamer als ja
schon also ich bin ja mit der deutschen
und griechischen kultur aufgewachsen und
meine deutsche mutter hat immer sehr
viel griechisch gekocht das macht sie
bis heute noch sie backt auch im
gegensatz zu mir passt meine mutter sehr
gut und ja das griechisches immer
allgegenwärtig gewesen weil also ich
will jetzt hier niemanden laufen auf den
schlips treten aber die griechische
krise hat natürlich auch genauso wie die
türkischen oder
schon einiges zu bieten
und ja das war immer allgegenwärtig und
wir haben geschaut dass alles wieder
verwendet wurde ist haben überall
alufolie oder frischhaltefolie darüber
es wurde alles nochmal eingepackt alles
haben wir den kühlschrank wurde es wurde
am nächsten tag was komplett neues haus
gezaubert aber ja aber noch viel mehr
kenne ich das nochmal nach oman
griechenland sehr hatte eine ganz kleine
küche mein vater stammt aus athen aus
der großstadt und meine oma hatte eine
wohnung in athen und die küche war ganz
kleiner wenn ich sage klein meine ich
zwei meter mal 2 meter
kleiner kochbereich ein kleiner tisch
und sie hat in dieser kleinen kammer hat
sie gezaubert und gekocht und ist auch
markt gegangen und kam voll bepackt mit
ihrem rolli wieder vermarkten sollte das
zum dm lea und dann wurde was daraus
gezaubert war schon auf frieden weißt du
hast ja mitgemacht wahrscheinlich ne
leider hat es reise platin lauf über
auch noch schutz platten drauf haben ja
genau auch schön und da gab es auch
nichts neumodisches also wenn meine
mutter zum beispiel frittiert meine
montag eine friteuse meiner mutter hat
und ob mehr da ist ein sieg drin gitter
das macht sie vorher mit öl und darin
frittiert meine mutter also so ganz
einfach das ist genau und wie wir backen
auf und ich auch wenn ich was baku dazu
bereite in einem taxi in einem blech ja
genau diese gesteine fachen runden
millimeter dünnen blechen und das ist
schon was besonderes das definitiv schön
kochen ist schön
also eigentlich war es geschafft suppe
das köchelt muss ich hin der reis
gespielt vor sich hin ich mache hier
eben sauber gedacht ist doch ein
ausruhen und dann schreibt man es gleich
zum joghurt
also einfach aber jetzt schon fertig
gekocht aber ich konnte natürlich dieser
süßen zuckerschoten nicht widerstehen
natürlich gibt es sachen bisher ja
vorgeschlagen kniffe
lecker kennst du ja ja ich kenne ich leb
ich liebe annie zubereitet
deswegen das mache weiß ist schön mal
kannst super vorbereiten im kühlschrank
lagern und dann jederzeit sich dafür
einfach mal machen da wir schon mal hier
im zuckersirup aufgesetzt der ist
einfach nur zucker und wasser das rezept
gibt es auf dem blog könnte schauen was
da noch reinkommt bisschen zitronensaft
moment mag sogar zum spritzer mit rein
geben ja
und was ihr dafür braucht sind teig
fäden die gibt's meist im türkischen
supermarkt manchmal kurz die messer noch
mal her guck mal was übrigens mozzarella
ja
also die disney vorbereitung ich habe
hier mal die teig werden wie gesagt die
gibt's im türkisch und super läuft genau
zitronensaft habe ein bisschen zum sirup
dazu
und da brauchen wir noch ein bisschen
mozzarella und viel butter sehr viel
butter der sicher schnitte dass ich die
chance hätte das ist ja schon sicher
schnell das ist schnitte des sicher
schon das ist ja schon etwas
was haben die teig beten zwischendurch
zitrone in die spülmaschine
ja ich mache ja auch immer mit einer
ausgepressten zitrone glaubt ihr
wirklich immer nicht immer habe da er so
ich bin ein bisschen geruchssinn haben
dann ja sehr immer darf sie kennen den
zuckersirup darein gießen da könnte
schneller und die zucker zu gefährden
die teig fäden schön klein schneiden
aber ich sehe die sind ja schon perfekt
die sind schon geschnitten und was ich
jetzt machen werde bisschen von meiner
mutter hier irgendwelche und am besten
nehmt ihr euch auch so kleine firmen
oder wenig eine kleine hat halt ein
großes aber so hat man halt schöne
kleine kasernen und die butter kommt
jetzt da ist wirklich eine kleine
portion deswegen ich ja so
und die butter kommt am ehesten die
schmelzender im blech durch dir so ein
tai chi chuan der g ba
geht mein lieblingsteil spannung und
dann gebe ich hier wirklich in datteln
sirup dazu trauben sirup ist aber auch
droht da kann man das hier nämlich schön
wo ist der ursprung schon im gericht
also ich würde jetzt behaupten die tür
keine
ja und wie kam es dazu aber libanesen
würden jetzt behaupten im libanon
arabische doch erstmal mit dem wackler
war ja da geht aber richtig die brocken
da rede ich die die schlagende die nasa
ein wenn du sagst es ist von den türken
oder von den griechen ganz genau
deswegen fragt man das verstehen viele
keinen spaß deswegen bleiben wir dabei
baklava mickrig nerven
[Musik]
hier darfst du gerne ein bisschen
auskleiden und ich werde gleich die teig
werden einfach mit der butter
verrühren ok während du das machst ich
will jetzt einfach dir einfach die
aufgaben übergeben da gern weil ich habe
noch ein paar fragen an dich aus der
komische arbeiter auf anweisung immer
gründlich das einen tollen humor sagt
man so klar frühstück dann würdest du in
deinem leben am meisten geprägt geprägt
die frage passt zwar nicht zu dem mit
dem humor aber egal ich glaube das was
viel mit mir gemacht hat waren die
enttäuschungen und die schmerzen seiten
ich glaube da dadurch lernt man am
meisten kommt immer darauf an was man
die energie umwandelt ich hoffe doch
etwas gutes und
geprägt dadurch als ich raus bekommen
habe dass ich alles haben kann was ich
möchte
wenn ich das visualisiere dass auf
einmal ging es los ist bei dir auch so
oder glaubst du es gibt grenzen für dich
noch
ich glaube die grenzen setzt man sich
selber ich glaube so kann man schon
immer alles erreichen was man sich
vornimmt wenn es realistische ziele sind
und wenn man auch wenn sich dinge
vornimmt wofür man und soziales umfeld
braucht so wie jetzt ich zb ich mache
den rückhalt der familie oma und opa
mein mann allein könnte ich das nicht
stemmen wenn ich mir das jetzt alleine
vornehmen würde würde ich das nicht
schaffen außer ich müsste mir das umfeld
bauen ja aber ich glaube wenn man ziele
für sich selbst gesetzt hat dann kann
man sie schon realistisch na ja klar
klein sind deine träume rechner also bin
ich da es ja immer wieder wenn man hier
ein pferd das ist ja jetzt nicht
beschlossen ist also bescheiden schreibt
man anders
palast dem dorf hier brauche es für die
aber
was ist dir bei einem mann wichtig
der muss klug sein weil ich ja auch ganz
pfiffig bin ich mag menschen die sehr
geradeaus sind weil ich es auch bin ja
nicht so den heißen brei reden
ich finde humor ganz toll aber ich liebe
humor und ja da muss besessen sein von
mir
aber noch in einem gesunden maß oder
nicht besessen und spendabel ja
du verstehst du dich eigentlich mit
einer unserer das ist ein ganz zwei
bezaubernde hübsche wesen die sich
unterschiedlich wahrnehmen
ja ich bin sie einfach zucker und bin
ganz hin und weg muss dazu sagen samira
ist jetzt so kann man das sagen
nimmst ja dann nimmt er dann noch mal
andere form und farbe an und die ella
die ist halt also heute morgen gehört
die ella halt immer man hört die ella
immer immer
und ich bin heute morgen irgendwie
wachgeworden mitten in der nacht es war
noch dunkel ich war eigentlich noch im
sandmann beschäftigt und die ella ist ja
dann schon auf ex zu sehen also ich hab
mich morgen genau da eine stufe runter
und dann rief sie den hund hat den wall
verschluckt galerie hat den ball doch
die hat den ball verschluckt also es war
fiel heute morgen naja die leister immer
die wacht auf und ist sofort dass das
wahnsinn ist
nicollette ein richtiger name oder ein
künstlername
fragen sich manche ich glaube das ist so
wie bei tier und mit sally und salina
aber ich musste stark überlegen wären
nicht die kollektion wir warten ja wir
müssen es auch nur eine handvoll
menschen die die salih hat zu mir sagen
ja eine schräg auch dass sie es sehr
lustig findet dass du manchmal so
genervt aussiehst beim backen obwohl wir
gerne mit mir wachsen nein ich bin gar
nicht genervt müsste was mit videos auf
gewalt ist ich mache den kopf immer nach
hinten hat ein doppelkinn so als wenn
ich konzentriert bin ein
markus schreibt wie schaffst du es so
positiv zu sein ich wohne im ausland und
kämpfe mit heimweh
also wahrscheinlich jetzt keinen tipp
gegen heimweh weil ich verspüre kein
heimweh wohne da wo ich zu hause bin
aber positiv zu sein wo ich glaube dass
das leben schon geschenkt ist ich
versuche viel dankbarkeit empfinden wird
das was da ist und glaube oder ich bin
mir bewusst darüber dass das leben
begrenzt das weißt du und es gibt andere
menschen die wären gerne in meiner
position oder in seiner wir haben heute
morgen schlimme nachrichten bekommen
oder irgendwas ganz furchtbares sie
würdigten sich sie könnten jetzt mein
entspanntes mindset haben und das mache
ich mir irgendwie immer wieder klar ja
das ist nicht selbstverständlich weiß
warum aber ist sie manchmal auch dass
reste
und damit meine ich nicht beim backen
kann augen genervt beiden und auch
schlecht gelaunt
sehr schnell nein nein
ja das ist schon vorbereitet und jetzt
nehmen wir uns diese pfännchen gemein
haben jetzt zusammen
[Musik]
eine hälfte kommt nämlich unten rein
und dann kann man das so ein bisschen
festdrücken mit einem glas oder mit
einem mit einer burger presse
tatsächlich waren es schon vor
geschnittene teig werden ja die sind
bisschen zu feiern also immer dahin wo
es am markt ja die gibt es auch nicht
vor geschnitten aber das macht nichts
und dann kommt eine schicht käserei zu
nehmen wir zum mozzarella
für die kombi käse und süß ich glaube
dass kennt nicht jeder
erklärt den leuten doch mal was könig
ist der könig ist mit diesen typischen
teig fäden
die werden mit ein wenig butter vermengt
und
kommen dann im backofen der käse
dazwischen der schmilzt dann nämlich
wundervoll das ist wieder mit dabei war
ja ja natürlich und
der zoo kassierung der kühlt gerade
schon ab und kommt dann später kalt über
das warme küche und wenn man das dann
ist das eine geschmacksexplosion
überall schön käse ich hatte meine
arbeitskollegin vor einigen jahren
lieber schwanger und die hat fast jeden
tag ein zwei kündigen sich mitgebracht
die war in den letzten schritten und die
hatte richtig richter leistungen ja ja
und die hat das so weggehauen durch die
habe ich das ende lernt man als ich dann
paar mal probiert habe ist schreckt
natürlich ohne fast merck gut aber es
ist ja auch schwer süß und als ich
gesehen habe dass sie da ein zwei dinge
am tag davon gemacht boah wie viel hat
sie zugenommen in der schwangerschaft
ist die frage ja aber jetzt geschmeckt
das ist die hauptsache ist ja als ich
jetzt noch die schicht drauf dann kommt
es gleich den ofen aber wir packen es
erst in den ofen wenn wir unser haupt
ganz probiert haben dann aber vorher
kommt gleich unser showmaster der tag ja
ja ja jetzt ein spiel okay okay ich
fühle die butter
vorgekommen in der cloud und setzte
spielregeln
[Applaus]
let's go wir fangen an mit sophie sagte
das nein du musst mir bist du ganz
genaues stück für stück erklärt ok ich
gebe euch ein begriff wir dürfen nicht
gucken ob du hast freund schon nein wir
haben börsen lagen die giga und zähle
jetzt so gemacht so gesellige man ja
genauso wenn sie gleich gewinnt ist der
woran es liegt jetzt kann ich ja gar
nicht mehr gewinnen wie man es so dass
wir sogar neue spielregeln haben ja das
bedeutet ich gebe euch jetzt erstmal ein
begriff während ihr müsst dazu einen
song bin ja in dem dieser begriff bock
kann gerne auch im songtext drin sein
oder im titel das also durchaus den
titel sondern ok genau und wir machen
das so dass im gleichlauf
letztes mal wenn ich so ein weil das
sich nicht crazy in love me crazy in
love nicht eingefallen ist
also ich war die eigentliche stimme von
whitney houston
später noch karaoke von maria
ja er war ich mache doch alles alles
ein bisschen länger dauern aber haben
die nachfolgenden sendungen haben sich
um eine stunde aber da muss ich das
mikro hier so wegnehmen aber nicht man
hat den song müssen wir schon raus
schreien weil du musst noch schnell
sein der hockey league los
ist lautet
verdammt ich lieb dich
verdammt ich brauch dich brauche ich
nicht damit ich will dich will ich nicht
wähle ich nicht verlieren
[Applaus]
ok jetzt hast du bestimmt am mikrofon
war das nun eigentlich
weniger
rabatte 52 badesee in mittelamerika was
du sagst durch geraten sind wie tsv dass
die vietnamesische
korean alten von sommer
ist ein herz ist deutlich geld oder wir
sind hertha
kenne hier geht es immer so wir sind
schon sehr erfolgreich
[Musik]
okay ein punkt zeitpunkt dafür ist warum
schreibst du mich gesungen hat ja ich
hab's erraten und gesungen wird von auch
zwei punkte gekriegt aber
nichts begriffen
die kokosnuss
ich bin etwas enttäuscht
hat ein äffchen und ein pferd und jeder
der uns mark kriegt unser einmaleins
gelehrt zwei mal drei macht ihr budget
widmen drei macht neune
wichtig
für dich
langstrumpf wie kann ich es nur
vergessen hier ihr habt sogar noch der
song davon gehabt dafür
hätte ich aber natürlich gewünscht
hätte mir baby one more time
goes by
her
und wir beide wieder gleichzeitig schon
wieder kommen jetzt wieder mal die dann
kommen wir auch das lied
in mir nicht die arbeitsplätze weg
[Gelächter]
mit dir
ich kann einfach nur im hintergrund okay
sagte dehm der dpa
und den gangsta-rap in meinem kopf
verdrehen
der iq
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wie madame so noch zwei begriffen jetzt
aber ich spanne mit
kaiser heißt
es wieder
einmal klärwärter 111 personen sprechen
hier das geht so nicht
[Gelächter]
ich weiß wir sollten auch zu sagen eine
grund geht ja wie nennen wir unsere
beweisen ob er das niveau
[Gelächter]
ach das war mord
ich glaube du hast gewonnen
okay die nächste runde geht an item shop
[Musik]
so was so richtig schön anrichten mit
seinem erstellt ja gerne
mal die die sind nicht so sich
der macht den reiz und ich mache
ist über der essensausgabe ja in seiner
schule machen sich darauf genauso zum
ramadan wird ja immer so glücklich hier
besteht eine da oder einer da und macht
den reiz der andere noch das andere
gestützt darauf lasse ich noch drauf
noch nie so eine schöne leckere
unterhaltsame kochsendung gesehen wir
sind auch ja wir brauchen eine eigene
show machen die colette wird 2 eine
players ach so das kulinarische ok und
dann machen wir da zusammen die gäste
fertigen wir gehabt finde ich gut das
ist quasi jetzt eine aufforderung an
free tv ja ich liebe weißt du warum
können wir auch gerne hauptsache frauen
bekommen eine zugbindung ja ich nehme
ich alles mit sich trägt ihre
allerhöchste zeit und das ist viel zu
wenig frauen die kochen und naja direkte
schalte ich jetzt mal für mich
war ja das ist eigentlich nicht groß
oder
omega was noch alles alles mit joghurt
guckt euch das dann ja
lecker guten appetit wie sagt man auch
wirklich wieder so drauf ist und auf
griechisch kann ich dir gar nicht sagen
wir honorieren oder radio taxi sagt nach
griechisch gesundheit
china ist auch so ein schönes gemüse ja
schön und lecker toll dass es kurz und
dann zeigen wir euch gleich noch ein ass
[Musik]
muss sagen ich habe es doch noch mal
gemacht mit teig werden die nicht
geschnitten sind weil die anderen der zu
viel butter aufgezogen hohle sprüche
noch einen löffel und jetzt kommt
nämlich mein paarweise mit katze und
hund richtig deswegen nebengeräusche ist
japan i sit ja ja und
jetzt kommt hier der kalte sirup drauf
normal kommt er auch eiskalt seiner
blubbert es noch so richtig nah und ich
finde man muss beim sirup schon ein
bisschen sparsam sein also es gibt
wirklich menschen die hauen ordentlich
was rein und dann ist es aber zu süß
und ich servierte
j
wir haben mehr richtig chaos haushalt so
nicolette hin und mitgebrachter die
maschine sei auf der flucht mache
sowieso noch so ein bisschen im streit
mit der ziele mit unserer zweiten katze
dass es hier chaos haushalt ich sag's
euch ja das ist unser kniffe
probier mal und das tolle ist
der käse da drin
das ist einfach gut wahrscheinlich
gewöhnt heißt ja ja sehr heiß aufpassen
und entweder ist man dazu jetzt etwas
joghurt nur diesen türkischen
stichfesten joghurt etwas eis oder
heimat ist türkische eis das türkisch
teil waren produkte
ist es so roth
ein bisschen angst
ist einfach nur frittierte butter
frittierte teig werden in butter also
käse butter und zucker zum einen geräte
also oder
das ist unsere fraktion für uns beide
sagen nein haben jetzt die sachen waren
zum shoppen
das ist so gut ihr müsst das
ausprobieren schnell gemacht da bot der
vergabe der heutige band hätte den
gürtel noch mal hier vorne zu sprengen
die teilnehmer auch wenn jedes mal
gefragt ob ich schwanger bin aber ich
bin es nicht ich selbst fragen was wir
immer immer fragt man zum beispiel bist
du schwanger wird auf rang man manche
fragen auch nicht manche sagen oh sie
ist schwanger
toll dass du das weißt
okay wir gehen das packen wir noch 1 1
ich muss mir noch um zehn ja weil ich
jetzt noch ein ass dann kommen ganz
kleines de glanz auch nicht nervös
[Musik]
bis da niemand die
düsseldorfer francisco
[Gelächter]
jetzt kommen wir dahin keine sau da
sein wird kann diesen slogan wir machen
man bei wmf ist mehr los
[Gelächter]
als ich deine ansichten wein in der luft
gesehen
dahin
gemacht obwohl ich liebe dich auch der
sache ist es richtig
freuen konnte dass letzten aufnahmen und
der härter und ich getrennt
der hält sich gesagt ab reinen die alte
da kennen sie keine gnade da bremsen ich
sag's dem 180 durch die 30er zone das
ist das liebste motto im bett
hat die langsamen der blitz hat schon
zwei mal ausgeschlagen und
wer will eigentlich ist videos schneiden
man sitzt ja einem lkw die trucker babes
doch auch ein geiles formats für uns
oder die trucker babes wie zwei mit dem
lkw aber mit einem sally truck beliefern
wir einmal deutschland die läden super
spiele die karaoke playlist von spotify
ja liebe leserin minister
[Musik]
lieber papi
solarium techniker du erstmal zum tolga
er liebt euch der brauchten solarium
technik ab da war der gesichtshaut zu
stark eingestellt party
[Musik]
bevor hochgehen zeige ich dir erstmal
draußen die leinwand
[Musik]
normalerweise muss man gar nicht raus
aber ich wollte etwas zeigen
wie schön oder gar mit kamera ist es
kalt so lange müssen wir jetzt hier
durch den regen naja ok zum einen gab
aber normalerweise auf zu grob und
fertig
[Musik]
und da sind wir
willkommen dankeschön kommt rein hallo
hallo
[Musik]
das ist viel größer ist als ich gedacht
habe und jetzt sieht man halt auch eben
erstmalig für produktvielfalt ist das
ist ja bist ja unnormal und
wunderschön ich bin ja sonst findet jede
ecken hier entdeckt also das sind wir
ich muss jetzt gleich mal hier ankommt
das heißt sie mit nach haus schumacher
ja ich bin hier zu hause unbedingt und
dann habe ich mir überlegt dass wir zu
machen ich sag dir im gericht oder
kuchen und du suchst alles werkzeug was
du dafür brauchst und wir machen es wie
im super zeit gehabt eine begrenzte zeit
wie viel ich würde sagen der laden schon
groß wird in der viertelstunde geben das
ist viel zu lang solange
ich würde sagen ich gebe die fünf
minuten ja du rennst du den laden
schaust was zu bekommen wären in einigen
bereichen die 5 mio und dann gucken wir
auf alles richtig ist total super blick
reinwerfen nicht wohl kommt man aus es
ist ja ich habe schon das ist ja so
unfassbar riesig weiß man gar nicht wo
man zuerst hinschauen soll aber wir sind
guter dinge ja aber ich brauche
helferlein ja ich hol dir den thema
design rot
für mich
werden immer kurzen
wagen ja okay dann auf die plätze timm
herr timm her denn los ich bezahlt hallo
tim denn du bist mein fahrer heute
nicolet besorgt bitte alles am werkzeug
und zutaten was bekommen kannst um eine
donauwelle dem konto novelle und gulasch
com
ok dort das zu den küchenmaschinen geht
es ist nicht einfach zu den kirchen
möchte hierzu den küchenmaschinen oh
mein gott was habe ich getan was habe
ich getan
so super ok dass wir brauchen dafür
daheim streits nicht doch für
gesprochenes mehr
so ok moment hier besteht darin wie man
gulasch macht und hier steht drin wie
man hört so novelle macht es braucht man
auch das brauchen wir auf jeden fall
29.90 die hat den rat ab
lecker hat sie mir mal geschickt war
richtig gut da können wir auch mal ein
paar mehr nehmen weil war richtig
schweine lecker das habe ich getan was
habe ich getan
nach vier minuten
ja ich kann nicht exakt mich nicht so
stressig wie vanille extrakt überall
rein gebrauchen topf schnell wir
brauchen einen job den wir hier brauchen
wir der ist wichtig bis gulasch oder
[Musik]
und wir schneiden da drauf auf dem orad
orad
schön herzhaft
ja
ok weiter weiter
wie ist die zeit 2 minuten das schaffen
wir das geht ohne probleme
letzter minute ja ich habe gleich alles
für die donauwelle
[Musik]
so
fertig jetzt
hast du noch 50 sekunden ja was soll ich
machen dann nehmen wir noch besteck und
das gute essen oder das hier und das
hier
so das war's
fertig ende
[Musik]
jetzt ist aus musste aber richtig aber
eine herausforderung das ist war nach
aufforderung und jetzt kommt noch mal
tolga unser spiel master ehrmann spiel
vorbereitet ich bin schon gespannt
darauf eigentlich wollte ich ja keinen
wissensspiel weil ich mir dachte kommen
jetzt haben wir schon so viel ja aber es
ist kopf an kopf weist sie wird sich
jetzt noch irgendwie scheinen jetzt
machen wird ist ja okay
es gibt eigentlich keine spielregeln ach
so spielen wer weiß denn so was es gibt
drei antwortmöglichkeiten und ihr sagt
dann ich wünsche ihr stehen
sie hat auch schon gesehen an der wand
hängt das bild hoffnung ja da hängt
behalten die komplette bundle ist ganz
groß ja ich musste auch nur zehn mal in
die sendung kommen damit ist auch die
wahl geschafft habe andere schaffen es
beim halben x
ach so sollen wir vielleicht was zum ach
so aber schlecht vorbereitet
[Applaus]
wer die waschmaschine schonen möchte
sollte
die ölverschmierte lappen lieber
flüssigwaschmittel nutzen b mit
tierhaaren verschmutzte kleidung auf
links drehen
sandiger badetücher nach dem
strandbesuch nicht sofort waschen
habe ich gezeigt ich ja ich glaube die
muss man bestimmt vorher 3 aus ja
wir haben beide einen punkt
kommen wir zur zweiten frage eine frage
die ihr beide wissen solltet aber die
serie heißt denn so was oder wer weiß
es geht ums kochen
um ein fischfilet mit haut gleichmäßig
goldbraun braten sollte der fisch in die
kalte pfanne gelegt und dann erhitzt
werden
vor dem vorbereiten mit sprudel wasser
benetzt werden sie vorher für 30
sekunden die mikrowelle erwärmt werden
es wird jetzt das nicht verraten wird
dass neben weil ich glaube und
sternekoch arbeitet doch nicht mit einer
mikrowelle
ihr seid beide wichtige arbeit
jeweils als ob mein ich mache den
fischern die heiße fahren dann geht
immer um so erwärmt dass ich dann
gleichmäßig mit ente macht man das auto
ja mit dem peking ente mit ihnen ich
habe die andere knusper ente auf der
mutter täglich
gehen
kann haben wir
[Applaus]
gewinnen
wird gleich
ärger gibt er mir
die leute die gar nicht richtig
langweilig
okay der anelka auch ein italienisches
unternehmen nutzt die abfälle der
zitrone frucht industrie und produziert
daraus veganes katzenfutter
verarbeitet sie zur kleidung c stellt
daraus umweltfreundlich textmarker
textmarker
[Musik]
ich hab
da gibt es
ja die riecht nach zitrone ja aber ich
nicht habe ich hatte ich habe ja aber
geschenkt aber hat es wirklich war nein
weil die
guckt auch abwägen ist auch soweit ja
ich hab ich konnte immer genau wissen
dass du meine rezepte ab guckst du deine
videos so lange auf ihr
sohn xr frage ein regenwurm sieht in der
nacht bis zu 20 blätter in seinem roller
wie kann das 200 fache seines
körpergewichts stemmen
sie haben gesagt okay c kann sich auf
zehn prozent seines ausgestreckten größe
zusammenziehen
beide falsch
in einer nacht bis zu 20 litern was
macht man mit den blättern der essen
oder ach
guck dir sogar die fehler ab mai
nur
noch eine frage
muss jetzt ist dieses gleich
am ende hab mich da immer als
spielmacher eine schätzfrage im petto
haben eine schätzfrage da gibt es immer
richtig oder falsch
warum sollte ein feuchter schwamm wasser
besser auf als ein trockener a
der unterdruck in dem schwamm röhre ist
aufgehoben
b es hat sich rein reibung semmeln das
fett in der kammern gelöst die bereits
vorhandene flüssigkeit sieht weitere
flüssigkeit an ja
kapellari tät heißt das
papier
schwarz frage
wie viel wasser ist hier noch zwei
drittel
ach so ein liter in milliliter aber das
ist der pott mann ich weiß noch nicht
wie viel volumen des hartz iv
mehr wetten du weißt wie viel wasser
daran habe ich bin ja oder nein
das ist zu viel
ich frag ja okay ich bin mir nicht mehr
sicher ich glaube ich habe zuviel
das geht übrigens nur weil vor rose
liegt glas ist will ich nur mal sagen
wenn ihr das zu hause nach ihrer ist
immer noch gern was macht das hier
richtig
dann springt er das wusste der
torrichter
oha hatte gehässig gesagt hat noch eine
menge
was da gerade richtig gehässig gesagt
auf dem fall micro auf die ganze zeit
was da gar nicht so stolze
[Gelächter]
js heißt ja also ich hab 1190 ich hab
2230 der dann beliefen ja dran aber
[Musik]
es ist eben bisschen mehr punkte also
müssen wir gucken wie es aussieht die
momentan ist der punktestand
freund 12 zu 10 die punkte dazwischen 16
du hast gewonnen dass er echt geworden
ich weiß ja ja wo ich jetzt ein paar
junge starke männer und dann haben die
meinen einkauf frau und stich und die
kann es einfach mit mir mega wird
altmark ticket auch die jungen
[Musik]
ok jetzt hast du geworden tatsächlich
alles mitmensch super danke ja nur dem
team lässt du da macht er es nicht mit
inkludiert haben wir ja auch wieder raus
denn
bitteschön gerne
wiedersehen
[Applaus]
freuen
es geht schon ttv ii
[Musik]